helens que está intentando hacer todo lo
posible para negociar en la evacuación
del batallón de azov que todavía resiste
en la acería mariupol lleva siendo
ocupada por el ejército ruso desde hace
casi más de un mes pero esos
combatientes resisten en la acería y hay
muchos que están heridos y necesitan ser
evacuados fuertemente sin embargo su
viceministra ya ha avisado que estas
negociaciones no van a ser fáciles y se
muestra pesimista porque en las
negociaciones van a tener que hacer
concesiones y esto no va a gustar a todo
el mundo piden también la ayuda de
europa y de la comunidad internacional
para poder mediar en esta situación la
acería de mariupol
resiste después de dos meses en esta
invasión rusa y se ha convertido ya en
un icono en todo este país en ucrania